[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day it's the
end of the summer things are heating up
there's a vent Sevilla Mazer tonight
we're gonna get to that but first I want
to talk about the WWE SummerSlam at the
Barclays in Brooklyn yesterday throw up
that clip Jillian look at this photo
that's our own Rhinebeck at SummerSlam
yep he's having fun who's that guy
Anthony DeVito my buddy that's a man
having fun at the WWE summerslam tell us
about the event itself was really
exciting a Barclays Center is great
because it's like it's very it's very
steep so all the sight lines are great
and like the sounds coming down and it
was like it was just very exciting yeah
cuz you seemed pretty high up section
109 it was pretty good let me start at
section one I heard they crowned a new
champion you did yeah spoiler alert it's
Roman reigns and nobody's happy about
this nobody would have been happy if it
was Brock Lesnar still either is he the
off-brands like Aquaman yeah yeah very
wet yeah and he he's always wet I don't
like him the fans don't like him
everybody boos him out of the bill
though the boos were so loud and I
texted my brother who's watching on the
on the WWE Network and he said that you
couldn't hear the boos because they were
like doing something with the crowd
noise well they cut out all the booze
from the producers when we do our show
yeah so as the winner
spoiler alert Roman reigns did he go on
a tour now or like what happened he's on
the show he'll be on Raw tonight and
they'll probably have some sort of
broster what do you think a tour of a
winner was like Miss America key for
that year is gonna do charity work wear
beautiful dresses
to make sure don't get out that sounds
riveting and Ryan was actually I had a
great time Hank we met about it and we
made a video segment that you can watch
shortly but before we get to that
there's a couple other stories I want to
talk about so it sounds like there's
some drama at the WWE from what Ryan was
saying there's also gonna be some drama
tonight at the MTV VMAs Jillian can you
show that photo again so this is a tweet
from a comedian named Caitlin bits a guy
who said when Kanye took that VMA from
Taylor I was like oh weird not this will
psychologically cripple both artists
driving them to madness
that's from last year's VMAs I thought
that was pretty funny but it reminded me
any tonight one reason why I love
watching the VMAs is hoping for drama
what's the drama gonna be tonight well
okay so Nicki Minaj and Safari are gonna
be at the VMAs and this is like since
they had that Twitter kerfuffle about
about her stabbing him was over him
getting stabbed by her and almost dying
and having to lie to the police so she
doesn't get arrested so holy allegedly
so fingers crossed there's a stabbing we
had a bit stabbing singer that's her ex
he had his hairline paid for by Nicki
Minaj yeah I heard he charged
prostitutes on her credit card that was
allegedly can't you just check the bank
statement to see what was in Safari face
no Nicki's cuz he charged it on her
account well he said though that she
gave him the card to be like feel free
to use however you need also you know
the other thing
about outfits and how we like that and
whatever else and then I catch it for
like in wrestling most of it is cool
entrances in neat outfit that is true I
did see whatever a little video of a
little video the demon right in Balor
yeah and I was like this feels like
Jesus Christ Superstar but like see
[Laughter]
listen WWE is a love of neat little
outfits so real quick I just want to do
a lightning round who do you thinks
gonna win for video of the Year at the
VMAs tonight Jordan it's this is America
I think God since when is any of his
budget he gave it to people Drake that's
like him he had 20 bucks there's nothing
interesting I'm gonna say this is
America as well obviously this is
America I'm gonna go oh man oh no you're
not why I mean I want to say everybody
else I'm picking the underdog
mm-hmm I want to make the most offer my
money if I put in 20 you know me yeah
we're all putting in $20 by the way and
that's who controls this world the
Carters it's gonna be a prick
oh hey there's a good video famously
snubbed at the VMAs before yeah famously
so just give me no stole that song
reducer is also tweeted we have the
final cut files the song has been in
production for years before that other
song so I believe I believe they miss a
[Music]
Hannah you have a shout out for us I do
this is from Philip Miller he says keep
making these videos again I do not know
if this is sarcasm you guys all have
such good chemistry
you mentioned desk and who sits there
but what are you doing at the desks I
heard in one episode someone say Jordan
is a writer but are you alright errs and
what shows do you write for it thanks
I'm really curious about the lore of
everyday I'm dead
so it sounds like sarcastic sounds
genuine to me well how could that whole
thing be sarcastic
you'd be surprised but yeah you know
we're writing a sketch series it's
coming out September 14 Ryan's up he
wrote that thing for the video and if
you stick around you'll see what he
wrote in just a second
Ryan was at WWE summerslam check it out
right now what's up I'm here at WWE
SummerSlam in Brooklyn New York and
we're catching up with the fans to see
how they prepare for the wrestling event
of the summer whoa
SummerSlam Oh watch this what do you
think's going on right now all the
people are waiting for it to go to some
of them and they're also saying would
people say it's fake and I say so is
half the movies look at this I found two
tag teams out here in front of the WWE
shop do you guys what's your names my
name is Samia Amanda my name is Bobby
ready for this and what's your name
Denzel how did you prepare for tonight
well we had two ton of Starbucks right
around you're just full of energy what's
up what's your name my name is James
everybody call me jo why do they call
you jo that's a long long story from the
90s is it your initials who are your
favorite wrestlers I have to say - Finn
Bower Finn Balor which who's your
favorite it's got to be AJ Styles gotta
go phenomenal AJ Styles or Finn Balor
they're both my my top to 2020 present
it's the way they walk Jackson
Schulman Seth Rollins Seth Rollins no
one said Seth Rollins yet everybody's
stupid ultimate warrior why is the
ultimate warrior favorite oh no he just
said he just didn't really give a crap
man he just did whatever he wanted
because he does that you can't see me
Jimmy Fox knuckle on during a giant
junkyard doll get it those tight blue
wrestles back then who are you most
looking forward to seeing Ronda Rousey
Ronda Rousey do you like the new day
dude that's crazy right right now that
you asked that right we all know new day
rocks but how many rocks can you name
how many rocks can you name how many
rocks can you name tiger eye opal
obsidian stag my diamond to the rock
emerald rock rubies rock man it's come
to my attention that you have one of the
largest collections of WWE figurines can
you tell me a little bit about that I
have right around 1400 Mattel WWE action
figures one of every wrestler that was
ever made ever ever got the joint the
clown to join the clowns what do you
think the value of your collection is
it's worth worth like $40,000 don't tell
my wife
Andy's married let me ask you this
why do you think Roman reigns is so wet
he's just so wet I don't know
you think he showers right before he
comes out probably Donovan I've got a
few characters that I'm coming up with
and I really just want to see what they
would sound like they came to life this
first character is called the nacho man
he's just like the macho man except he's
really into Mexican food oh yeah I'm the
T does not choose and when they eat
those nachos I'm gonna do the Taco Bell
splash cuz you ain't got nothing on the
nacho man oh yeah well let me tell you
something it's been spinner
rough couple of years from me I've been
losing my hair consistently for the past
thirty years my mustache looks like
something out of a bad Jackie Chan film
lukewarm steve austin so the bottom line
here is you know I'd like you all to
enjoy SummerSlam if you want and you
know that's that's kind of the bottom
line maybe the middle line because luke
lukewarm
steve austin asked so I like to watch
you guys earlier you brought up my
fantasy book background I also I bet I'm
the only person who actually wrestled in
high school I was on the restaurant oh
wow
my intro entrance and then the other boy
who gets the briefcase and there's money
in the bag Roman reigns why are you wet
this is every damn day
[Laughter]
[Music]
you